Well, good morning church.
Uh, if you're new to our church, we're glad you're here.
We're thankful that you would choose to worship with us.
We'd love to meet you if we can.
Uh, there's a big new here area out there in the lobby.
Uh, also if you call Henderson Hills home, uh,
we also love to see you.
It's great to gather together like this every week.
It's such a joy to be a family like that.
For the past couple months, we've been examining many facets
of the diamond called God's faithfulness.
How selected passages out of one Corinthians have shown us
that in unique ways, that he is faithful,
that he is trustworthy, he's dependable,
he is someone we can have full confidence in, someone
that we can base our whole lives on
and we can found our future and our present on.
And so today, in light of all of that,
just like we did last week, therefore four
because he is faithful,
therefore we are then empowered
to live a faithful life in response to respond
with faithfulness ourselves.
In other words, what changes for us
because of his faithfulness in our lives?
Well, go ahead and take your copy of God's word.
Turn with me to one Corinthians chapter 16.
Now one Corinthians 16, the end
of Paul's first letter to that church.
Many letters went like this,
that at the end they would put all these greetings
and thanksgivings in there for the people
that they were writing to.
And, and in the middle of all of
that they would sometimes insert
a quick summary of the letter.
And that's what this is. We'll see it here.
One Corinthians 16 verses 13 and 14.
Be watchful. Stand firm in the faith.
Act like men. Be strong.
Let all that you do be done in
love, God help us.
Two short verses, but so much here.
Holy Spirit, speak through your word today.
Speak to our hearts.
May we be good soil ready to receive this good word,
your gospel planted
and that you would bear fruit a hundredfold in our lives
to be doers, not just hearers of this word today.
You've gotta work in our hearts so we won't hear it.
So do it for your glory. Our good. In Jesus' name. Amen.
Now I know students, you're almost done with school
for the year, so you don't want me
to add any more onto it, of course.
But we need to do a quick grammar study of this passage
because it's gonna help us frame the rest
of this time together.
It's really, really important for us.
So look again at verse 13 as four commands right there.
You see those rapid fire one
after another seeming really quick.
But in language there is a thing called voice.
Not just that we're speaking, but it's referring to active
or middle or passive voice,
especially in the language this was
originally written in in Greek.
And so active means you are doing the action.
Middle means you're kind of doing it with you to yourself.
And passive means it's being done to you.
And that's really important here
because when you read this in English,
it sure seems like it's all just really forceful means.
Go stand firm, be stand alert, be strong.
It's, it's like this action of a general to his troops.
Almost a locker room speech, right? Kind of drum it up.
Let's get going as we run out the field, we're ready.
But we need to know the voices of each one of these
words here in the original language.
And so let's work through these four.
Be watchful is a present active verb.
It means you are to stay alert in an ongoing continual way.
Not just once, but ongoing. Then stand firm is also present.
Active means you need to remain constantly steadfast.
Well come back to all these here in a moment.
Act like men is present, middle.
Remember that's kind of this, putting it on consistently
yourself, almost like a robe wrapping it on.
But the fourth one, be strong
is a passive verb.
It's present. Passive means you're constantly receiving it.
It's still an imperative, which means it's a command
to continually be receiving strength.
Well, strength from whom? Well,
that's not just strength from some
outside source here on earth.
It's strength from the Lord.
It's from his faithfulness to us
that we've seen the whole series.
So be strengthened is the command.
Well, we take these four words
and what that means for us today then is
that God's strength enables us
to fight God's strength.
So we're taking these four as a group.
God's strength enables us the ability
to fight grants it to us, right?
It's the fourth of the four,
but it's really important 'cause it's passive.
So you're receiving the strength
to even do the other things.
So we can fight in this battle.
Now what battle am I talking about?
Well, it's the battle that Paul wrote against the entire
letter of one Corinthians,
that the Corinthians were tempted to side
with worldly truths rather than the the gospel.
Eternal truths. That's a battle, right?
The Corinthians were tempted
to divide within the church over leaders
or other things within the church.
That's a fight to overcome that temptation.
The Corinthians were tempted every day towards sexual
immorality and lawsuits and idolatry
and greed and gluttony.
Those are spiritual battles.
Listen, if you, and I think that coming
to Christ makes things easy.
We are way wrong in that thought
that our lives will be free from hardship.
That's kind of how it's sold at times, right?
Come to Jesus, all your problems go away. No, we're wrong.
The enemy comes after us when we follow Christ.
And so we need to rest in
and receive God's strength in order to fight well.
And so those other three commands
that fourth one's passive receive the strength.
The three commands before that give us the active ways
that we do fight in this battle of life.
The demeanor we have, you might say,
as we fight this battle.
So look again, it says first with alertness.
That's the first command he gives in verse 13, be watchful.
So fight with alertness in God's strength. Be watchful.
Constant readiness on the alert for a threat.
In fact, this is one of the common words Jesus used himself
in the parables he gave regarding the soon coming
judgment at the end of time.
And the way he said it was like, you know, if you knew,
if you knew that a thief was coming to break into your house
between two and 4:00 AM
you'd stay awake for that, wouldn't you?
Right? You would, you would.
You would stay alert if you're like, okay,
they told you they're coming so you would stay awake.
You would stay alert. That's the image.
Jesus paints with those parables.
Like if you know the robber's coming, you stay alert.
It's also the word that Jesus used
whenever he was in the garden with his disciples
before he was crucified.
And he said, come pray with me. But he said, remain here.
And the word he used was, watch with me. It's the same word.
It's stay awake is what he was saying.
Which if you know the story, they didn't
multiple times stay awake.
And so the idea here is that in God's strength,
in light of everything
that was coming at the Corinthians in their world,
they were to be watchful.
They were to stay alert at their posts.
They needed to stay guarded against the corrupting
influences in Corinth.
Jesus, in fact, in the garden.
He said it a little differently another time.
He said, watch again the same word, watch
and pray that you may not enter into temptation.
For the spirit is willing, but the flesh is weak.
Meaning you gotta stay diligent, stay on the ball, stay
alert against the corrupting influences,
the sinful temptations.
But they also needed to be alert, watchful
for the bad theology that was floating all
around them in Corinth, tempting them
to doubt the gospel truths that they knew and cherished.
Well think about that. Are those things not the same
kind of things that we need to be alert for?
It's not just in Corinth, it's in Edmond, it's in America.
Like don't we just as much tend to drift along
with the currents of the world just like they did tempted
to fall into the same traps that they did,
where we fall into sexual immorality
as anyone else in the world where we are tempted
to live, greedy self-centered lives just like
any unbeliever would.
It's right here where we can be tempted
to judge each other
and to treat each other based on social status rather than
shared status in Jesus Christ.
As brothers and sisters we're tempted with the same things.
It's like the frog. You've heard this analogy.
The frog in the the kettle, the pot on the stove, right?
You can very slowly turn the heat up on
the frog in the water.
He won't even notice. You know why?
Because he's a cold-blooded animal.
What that means is not his
spirit has anything that he's cold-blooded.
No he, he's cold-blooded means he, he adapts
to his environment.
We might say he accommodates
fits in to the environment in
which he is.
Let's not be the frog church. Let's not be the frog.
We need to be watchful for the rising temperature
of temptations to sin that are coming all around us
for the rising temperature of bad theology
that is just being saturated all over social
media, all over tv.
Not just coming from those false teachers,
but even coming from news.
So-called news stations,
the pull of the culture to just fit in,
to be just like everyone else.
That is this.
Be watchful, be alert to things that will grieve God,
to things that his word says, grieve.
And and in his strength,
his strength, we avoid them.
That's what it means to be watchful, to be with alertness,
to fight with alertness.
And that's actually the next imperative here.
In light of that stand firm, in the faith
stand firm, in the faith that God's strength
grants us the ability to fight with steadfastness,
with steadfast faith.
That phrase means to be firmly committed
in conviction and belief.
Here he says steadfast stand firm in the faith.
Now notice what he says. Not just stand firm in faith.
Stand firm in the faith.
That's the Jude one, three faith that was once
for all delivered to the saints.
That's the same faith that Peter, Paul,
John had in the early church.
That's the same faith we have that's based on the gospel.
His word. He's not talking about
stand firm in your personal faith
because man, I know myself that's pretty shaky.
It waivers based on how my day goes.
So if I stand firm in my faith, man,
I'm gonna be all over the map.
He says, stand firm in the faith, the gospel,
his word in Christ.
And that's the reason you can stand faith.
That's the reason I can stand firm in the faith,
because it's trustworthy, it's solid, it's based on someone
and something that is historically
and reasonable in its accuracy
that God has done this for us in Christ, the core doctrines
of Christianity.
It's, it's true and it's right and it's solid.
That means even in the face of opposition, even in the face
of temptation, even in the face of
what Ephesians four describes as every wind of doctrine,
human cunning, deceitful schemes, the enemy bringing out us,
even in the face of the waves of that just hammering,
hammering on the rock.
It's solid. It's solid.
Well, the battle's no different for us today,
church as to what they were feeling.
That's way he right this stand firm in the faith.
It's no different for us.
We are faced today with criticism
for our faith from every angle.
We are tempted every day to water down what we believe.
That's why just as much we must stand firm in the faith just
as much as they did back then in Corinth
because the enemy is gonna constantly try to chip away
at the exclusivity of Christ
at the uh, he, he's gonna tempt us to believe like
well surely everybody gets in right?
I mean God is love.
So isn't this universal
or even a lesser extent to what we call inclu inclusivism?
That's a hard word to say. Try it.
I inclusivism that means anyone who's genuine about seeking
after whoever God that they're seeking
after surely God gives them salvation too, right?
And the enemy just tosses those thoughts
and those little things into the world
and it starts to, to lodge into our minds that maybe we,
we really don't have the truth.
Maybe those things do sound right.
Maybe those things are right.
We have to stand firm in the faith.
Not only that the world will mock us
for rejecting the fleeting pleasures of sin so that we can
please our God so
that we can please him
and get made fun of mocked.
That's why we must stand firm in the faith.
I love how one author described, uh,
you might know the armor of God from Ephesians six.
There's, there's shoes if you didn't know that.
There's shoes in the armor of God.
Here's how one author described it.
Listen to verse 15 of Ephesians six.
It says as shoes for your feet.
This is the armor of God, shoes
for your feet having put on the readiness given
by the gospel of peace
that you've put on these kinds of shoes.
Now he's probably looking at a Roman
soldier as he's writing this.
And so a Roman soldier's shoes,
their sandals were low cut boots, boot like sandals
with straps that held them on kind
of going up the shin a little bit like that.
And fact, I saw some of you wearing them this morning.
Uh, it was interesting, uh, walking around today.
Anyway, um, but the souls on those sandals were thick
leather and they actually had short nails on the bottom
of them for grip.
They were almost like cleats if you've played sports right?
Those were not meant for running.
What they were meant for was for the soldier to dig in
and stand against the enemy
because all of the armor
of God is defensive apart
from the sword, which you could even argue.
The sword is defensive. It's kind
of just impaling the enemy, impales himself.
But, but the idea of all of it's defensive, even the shoes
that a soldier might get pushed.
But the goal is to stand, not slide as you're pushed
stand firm in the faith, right?
We are able to fight this battle of life
with steady feet
because of God's faithfulness to us in the gospel.
Notice that, right? The shoes
or the gospel, the readiness, the gospel of peace.
You're standing firm in the gospel.
Christ took the place of sinners like you and me.
I can stand on that. And as the enemy pushes,
the world pushes, we can stand fast.
But that takes courage, doesn't it?
It takes courage to stand firm in the faith when the
enemy comes at us.
It takes constant courage to fight in God's strength,
to stand firm, to not shrink, to not slide.
It takes courage,
which is the third command here in this verse,
which is translated in the ESV act like men
to play the man as some would translate it.
King James says, quit you like men.
I have no idea what that even means.
Uh, but that's what it says it.
The essence of that word is conduct
oneself in a courageous way.
Now, what Paul was not doing here,
'cause it sure sounds like it,
but it, he wasn't contrasting anything about
masculinity or femininity.
That's not what he's doing. He's merely using a common word
at the time that was used in a whole lot
of different context to contrast
full groundness with child likeness,
manhood with being a child.
Because think back to
what he said just a few chapters earlier.
This is one Corinthians 1311.
He says, when I was a child, I spoke like a child.
I thought like a child. I reasoned like a child.
When I became a man, I gave up childish ways.
See, that's what he's getting to here.
In other words, what he's saying there is when I matured,
when I grew up, I put away childish things.
So what he meant here in one Corinthians 16 was,
whether you're a man or a woman, he's not saying we all need
to act like men.
The call here was to grow up.
The call here was to mature, to act like an adult.
And an adult is courageous by definition.
This is not talking about some worldly definition
of manliness, like MMA fighting
or not crying ever in your life.
Like that's not what he's saying anything.
He's talking about gospel courage.
'cause think of Lydia in Philippi.
She hosted a church in her house that was risky
in a context like she was in.
It was risky, but she did it.
And then you think of Paul, his example over
and over where he's not strong man competition.
He's, he's preaching boldly in the face
of opposition and persecution.
That's courage, that's manliness in his context.
So to be courageous is to faithfully
carry out one's responsibilities even in the face
of opposition, even in the face of extreme danger.
Even in the face of frightening circumstances.
You do what you're supposed to do.
You don't give into fear, you don't give into hopelessness.
Listen, following Christ is not for cowards.
And I'm not talking just back in the first century
because there are more Christians being martyred
and imprisoned today than there
were back in the first century.
So yes, that's part of this.
But even every day you
and I are faced with this, this situation
or this moment or this conversation in which courage is
needed to stand firm in the faith
to do the right thing when the wrong thing means you would
get a bonus at work, takes courage
to boldly speak up whenever everyone else is doing something
and they start mocking you for not doing it.
And you speak up as to why takes courage
to care for the person that the rest
of the group is over here gossiping about
and you're caring for that person.
It takes courage.
And remember when we did the grammar study this,
this one's in the middle voice, which means
you put it on.
So, so you receive it from the Lord like a, like a robe
or a a coat or a jacket or something.
You receive it from the Lord,
but then you've gotta wrap yourself up in it.
You've gotta take courage, you've gotta put it on.
You can choose to apply it.
So what we're saying here is we're not saying you
gotta go be courageous.
You gotta go drum it up
and you gotta go like get in the mirror
before that big pitch before the bosses
and you start to, you know, ham, uh,
here we go, here we go, here we go.
I gotta go. You, you don't have to do that.
You don't have to have the courage drummed up,
manufactured in you.
No god's.
Remember, God's strength is what gives you the ability
to then go fight with mature courage.
He grants it to you, you wrap it up in it
and you walk, you fight.
And so again, church this like a general
to his soldiers before a battle.
This is how God's army us is to be.
We are to fight in his strength with alertness,
with steadfastness and with courage.
We are to fight. 'cause remember church, we are not,
the church is not meant to be a cruise ship where we get all
of our needs met, we get entertained
and we walk away too full from the buffet.
No, the church is meant to be a battleship
where every sailor has their assignment
from Captain Jesus.
And it's to go on this mission
that he has ordered for us to go on.
May that be what we are about here.
But this is not a cruise ship.
This is a battleship sending out,
coming back, getting filled up.
All of us have our assignment and we go on his mission.
And so that gets me a little fired up.
But, but here's what can happen.
If we just sat on those punchy phrases from verse 13,
we all kind of get motivated, get get going.
If we just stayed in verse 13, it could turn us
pretty harsh,
demanding it.
We could start to feel kind of angry, forceful,
get this kind of courage from the world feeling
and then we start blasting off on Facebook
and all kinds of different things because I'm standing firm.
That's why I believe Paul balanced it with verse 14
because look at verse 14 again.
Let all that you do be done
in love.
Now, that's not what a general would say to his troops right
before they go into the battle, right?
They're all out there ready to go fighting
and about to run into the front lines, right?
There he is. Like do it in love, right?
Like now he wouldn't do that,
but it is what he think about this.
It is what his speech would be
to his soldiers about the way they were
to treat one another, right?
You better love each other.
You may not like each other all the
time, but you're to love each other.
That's the way you are to treat one another, to things
that threaten the faith.
Yes, we must fight,
but to others, including our enemies, we are to love.
In reality. This verse verse 14, it,
it distills the whole letter into a single sentence
because love was a basic
but lacking ingredient
among the believers in the Corinth church,
which is again why Paul wrote chapter 13,
the famous love chapter
that's used at weddings all the time when it's really about
relationships within the church.
It works. Okay? I'm not gonna condemn you for saying it,
but notice the context.
It's about church relationships
and how we work together as the church.
If I speak in the tongues of men and of angels,
but have not love, I'm a noisy gong or a clinging symbol.
If I have prophetic powers understand all mysteries
and all knowledge, and if I have all faith so as
to remove mountains but have not love, I'm nothing.
If I give away all I have
and if I deliver up my body to be burned
but have not love, I gain nothing.
Love is patient and kind. Love does not envy or boast.
It is not arrogant or rude.
It does not insist on its own way.
It is not irritable or resentful.
It does not rejoice at wrongdoing,
but it rejoices with the truth.
Love bears all things, believes all things,
hopes all things, endures all things.
So now faith, hope and love abide these three.
But the greatest of these is love.
It's in the church, right?
But where do we get that kinda love?
'cause that's not just sentimental feeling, right?
Where do we get that kind of love again?
Like everything else? We can't come up with it on our own.
So just like we receive strength to fight,
we receive this love from God.
Romans five, verse five,
God's love has been poured into our hearts
through the Holy Spirit, like the container of your heart.
God opened it up, poured his love all the way into it.
And then you look at the classic lines all over one.
John says, we know love
because he laid down his life for us, love is from God.
Even this says this, God is love. Wow.
Then you have one John four 19,
the clearest explanation
of what we're talking about here today.
It says this, we love
because he first loved us.
In other words, God's love grants us the ability to love.
God's strength grants us the ability to fight.
God's love grants us the ability to love
his love for us.
Remember, it's not just sentimental feeling
that you can flippantly change based on circumstances.
This is love in sending his son to the world,
to give us life, to be the substitutionary payment
for our sins.
That's what love is
and that's what compels us to then love as well,
to love as Matthew 22, great commandment to love Him first
with all that we are because we've been born of God,
because we know God.
We can't do that unless he loved us first.
But then also not just to love him, to love others.
Like Paul said in one Corinthians 13,
because God's loved us in the way that he's loved us,
we can then love others like that.
That's what Paul said here in one Corinthians 16.
Everything we do must be done, done in love.
That's our motive.
To seek the best for someone else, to
willingly self-sacrifice for the good of someone else,
even when they don't deserve it.
And even when they could never pay me back. That's love.
Think about how that changes our response to God.
If, if he's loved us like he has our love for him,
then is okay.
My goal, God is to glorify you with everything that I am,
to make your name famous, to obey you and what you say
because you're worth it.
Even at the cost. It's gonna cost me. You're worth it.
And I give and I give and I give
because I love him for loving me first.
And then think about how it changes our response to others.
How do we react then horizontally
here, similar.
If God loved us in this way, we look for ways
to give to others.
We look for ways to elevate other people,
to serve them well, to make their lives better,
to also identify sin that is hurting them.
That's love because I want the best for you
because you want the best for me, sin is never God's best.
But it's not harsh, not brash.
It is love, gentle saying, Hey, come back to him.
Come back to him. And listen,
if the church in Corinth had been living according
to this principle of love,
then they would not have gotten themselves
into the messes that they did.
All throughout this letter. That's
what John Ctim said many, many years ago.
He said, if love had not been neglected,
then they would not have been puffed up.
They would not have divided over leaders.
They would not have brought lawsuits against one another.
They would not have committed
adultery with their father's wife.
They would not have despised the weaker brother.
They would not have been prideful about their own gifts.
If they had not neglected love,
they wouldn't have had all those problems.
That's how critical love is
even for us today.
And so yes, we have to have the courage
that we'll never retreat,
but we also must have the love that we're never fail.
So we're gonna worship together in a moment, church.
But I want you to think about this as we prepare for that
because God has loved us in this way.
We are now granted the ability
and the call to love him
and to love others in that same kind of way.
That's what a faithful life looks like.
If you're wondering, okay God, what are, what am I doing
that I need to be faithful in?
How can I be faithful? It's pretty simple.
It's terribly difficult
because the enemy's coming at you,
the world is coming at you.
Your own flesh is working against you. It's simple though.
It's not complicated. Don't overthink this.
What does a faithful life look like?
God's strength as he strengthens us.
It's being alert to things that might trip us up
and it's being courageously firm
in the faith that we sing about and talk about
and study about and worship
because of that's what a faithful life looks like.
Let's ask him to help us towards all that as we do it all in
love.